[Musik]
[Gelächter]
naja wie brot kann man diese folge
machen herzen kommt schneller wieder
leute falls ihr leute denkt dass wir
gemeinsam auf diesem kanal alles gesehen
haben was youtube und was dieses land an
geistig gestört und verhalten zu bieten
hat dann habt ihr euch getäuscht wenn
einige von euch haben sogar meine insel
die ms rhein gekleidet und habe mir ein
video geschickt mit der bitte das darauf
reagiere das ist wirklich also ganz im
ernst man mich gefragt hätte sebastian
was gibt es an gestörten leuten in
deutschland ich werde ich darauf
gekommen
ich hätte euch tausend dinge sagen
können ich will nicht aufkommen ja
allein bei diesem titel ist schon
komplett vorbei ist ein family stories
video und das video heißt die tauch
süchtige ja auch süchtig die taucht
süchtige elvira geht fremd wasser ist
mein element in der wir hoffen dass
unser leben aber mein mann jürgen werde
nicht mehr so richtig hat keinen bock
mehr
und da denke ich ehrlich über eine
scheidung nach weil was soll ich sonst
niemand perfekt an der stelle können wir
dieses video eigentlich auch fast schon
beenden weil wir schon den kompletten
case gemacht haben dafür dass dieser
frau höchstwahrscheinlich nicht zu
helfen ist also elvira ist nicht nur mir
auch ihr mann beide sind auch süchtig
ist das ding so also auf jeden fall die
beiden sind auch süchtig und der mann
hat auf einmal kein bock mehr
und dementsprechend denkt wir natürlich
als vernünftig denkender mensch an dem
punkt dann über die scheidung nach mal
ganz ehrlich ja also ich meine wirklich
alle waren alle schon mal in unserer
beziehung einen punkt mit dem partner
wurde partner einfach nicht mehr tauchen
wollte und dann kommst du denn jetzt
elvira idt okay es ist ein ehemann okay
ihr habt euch entschieden ihr leben
gemeinsam zu verbringen okay okay ich ja
wir waren verheiratet ja wir waren
dreißig jahre glücklich verheiratet
aber wenn du nicht mehr tauchen willst
du verdammter bastard dann vergisst du
dich wo kommst du dir jetzt noch mal
hoch nix zu futtern ja kann ich war
dafür aber kennst du wirst doch nicht
gestellt sie da irgendwas zu essen haben
wir schon keine gemeinsamkeiten mehr
ganz ehrlich hätte ich bin ein bisschen
schockiert dass man nicht besucht es
gerade mich zu verarbeiten also die frau
will jetzt allen ernstes ihr komplettes
familienleben wegwerfen ja und sie sagt
sie hat mit ihr mann gar keine
gemeinsamkeiten mehr weil er gerade
keine lust hat unter wasser zu sein
das ist so der grund dafür dass einfach
ist robert er beendet wird
ok klingt vernünftig
er ist einfach so elvira so sorry aber
ich habe keinen bock zu tauchen ganz
normal so ist als würde ich jetzt sagen
aber egal so als würde ich zu meiner
freundin sagen was man heute keine
spaghetti essen und sie war so verdammt
ich mach schluss und dann wirst du dich
jetzt wieder mal die frage für jeden
vernünftigen menschen was haben die
leute bei rtl2 gebraucht um auf die idee
zu kommen dass sie meine folge über eine
taucht süchtige frau machen sollten also
wie kommt ein mensch an diesem punkt an
im leben wo sich denkt denkt nächste
folge
die frau ist auch süchtig was kommt als
nächstes so bettina 51 ist süchtig nach
restmüll damit diese bei mir so dass ich
beruflich ziemlich im stress bin und
auch ziemlich wenig freizeit hier noch
habe und dann wird auch noch dazu mit
dieser ganzen rudel leiden habe ich den
moment kann schniefen darauf ja also
kann man einfach ganz normaler man so
eigentlich auch schon so ein lieber opa
schon fast nur seine fans jetzt schon
eigentlich ein bisschen eltern da
wahrscheinlich über 50 so richtung 60
da denkt man eigentlich so die ehe ist
halbwegs gefestigt man war jetzt 30
jahre verheiratet oder 40 und so läuft
wie ich mit elvira verstehen ich war mit
jürgen loos ist er hat keinen bock mehr
zu tauchen kein wasser kein nix mehr nur
zuhause abhängen sitzen
der kann doch nicht alles sein leute
ohne willst du wo sind menschen so im
leben falsch abgebogen dass sie so an
dem punkt angekommen wo so tauchen das
wichtigste ist im leben könnte ich das
vorstellen so was muss passiert sein
dass man sich so denkt so jung
tauchen ist mein ein und alles wenn ich
nicht mehr tauschen kann dann was daran
so geil digger du bist halt meinen kopf
unter wasser okay und da wo ihr wurden
also die reden so als würden sie aus
vollkommen oder so aus nordrhein
westfalen wo kann man da geht tauchen
die ja jedes gewässer hier ist entweder
total verschlammt oder grün zumindest
ist ungefähr so weit sehen ja egal wo es
ist grün mega tages gerettet was so
lieben trocken dauern zu wollen durch
den dicken ich hab kein bock mehr auf
die ohren
wenn man so auftauchen gewesen
irgendwann ist die luft raus sein die
luft ist nicht raus sie haben gerade
jetzt ist doch interessant ob
tatsächlich leute aber die tun mir auch
ein bisschen leid so die darstellerin
wirst du darstellen müssen einfach so
schauspieler das sieht auch süchtig sind
da habe ich mich angemeldet dadurch
kriegt jetzt wie eine hollywood rolle
oder so
wir haben da unsere hohe und schweden er
war ganz ehrlich also so wie sie jetzt
gerade mit ihm redet ich glaube ich
glaube ich würde doch tauchen geben mit
ihr ganz ehrlich unter wasser kann sein
zumindest nicht voll quatsch ich mit dem
ganzen bullshit ihr also ihr hier weil
man die beschaffung soll als ihr ehemann
ist jürgen jürgen wenn das hier gerade
sie ist mit sicherheit schaust du meinen
youtube-videos jürgen da gehe ich mal
von außen an der stelle einfach tauchen
mit ihren gibt doch noch anderes außer
tauchen ganz kurz stopp hat irgendjemand
einen freund oder so in so einer
irrenanstalt können denen vielleicht
kurz vorbei schicken weil ich glaub ja
bei aller liebe ich glaube sollte es mal
in der gummizelle tauchen gehen elvira
[Musik]
das ist tauchen
es ist das tauchen ok also der ganze
auftritt okay du wirst jetzt von deinem
mann scheiden lassen weil er nicht mit
dir im garten in ein planschbecken mit
zehn zentimeter wasser steigen will man
ist nicht grade eben noch was von da
unten haben wir unsere ruhe keiner
schreibt uns an wo unten
es sind cm wasser also ich lasse mir von
jürgen mein wasser nicht verlesen ich
setze mich jetzt schon in meinen kleinen
punkt habe gerade mein sechs flächen mit
und dann nehme ich mir richtig wie brot
kann man diese folge machen warum muss
denn alles boxen hätte sich rtl2 hätte
sie nicht wirklich einfach so die
zumindest mal wirklich tauchen lassen
können warum zur hölle muss sie in ihrem
garten in einem planschbecken sitzen mit
zehn zentimeter wasser und aus einem
über die
indem man ein ganzes welt mehr füllen
kann
sekt trinken warum muss warum tut ihr
uns an ohne masken machen
[Musik]
leute ihr müsst ganz ehrlich gestehen
mir fehlen ein bisschen die worte so
sieht tauchen bei elvira aus kann man
auf jeden fall verstehen dass man wenn
diese wirklich wunderbar erfüllende und
tiefgehende aktivität einem nicht mehr
geboten wird in der ehe das man dann
schluss markt und fremd geht das ist mir
auch ganz klar und verständlich
nur zu hause zu sitzen und trübsal
blasen ist für mich nix und es allemal
besser als sie zu einem psychiater zu
verbrennen und sich zu offenbaren nennen
stopp stopp stopp stopp stopp andersrum
es ist allemal besser zum psychiater zu
rennen als ich in den eigenen garten in
so ein kleines becken zu setzen und die
zeitung zu lesen ich gedacht nee was
heißt dein leben und da kannst auch
entspannen und das besser als jeder
psychiater wenn jeder meint der kanadier
verwiesen werden mit mir im wasser jeder
hat er sich aber getäuscht
was ist überhaupt wo kriegt man sowas
her also ohne witzig ich wüsste nicht
wofür das ursprünglich gedacht ist weil
das hier was sie gerade eine hand hätte
safe nicht als als glas oder gefäß für
getränke gedacht wofür wird die ist
dieses total ursprünglich gedacht sagt
er wird aber in den kommentaren also ich
habe noch die möglichkeit mit wasser der
wir ganz ehrlich jürgen so mal hier ein
ernstes wort unter männern im vertrauen
will ich dir geben lasst es die alte hat
wirklich einen schlag weg dass es
scheppert okay lasst sie an ihrem plan
sprechen da sitzen nimmt das nötigste
mitnehmen ein portmonee mit vielleicht
noch ein gutes buch und dann ab dafür
aber ist doch nicht dein ernst war durch
betreibt wenn du so gemein biester ich
kann ja nicht wetter open man dauernd so
ist kaputt dann auch reebok habe ich
auch nicht weil er kann nicht mehr 1000
bürger warum zur hölle braucht man im
tauchanzug für dieses land stecken würde
die logik erschließt sich mir nicht also
bei aller liebe leute ich glaube bei
jeder sache im leben gibt es ein limit
und man sollte seine grenzen kennen
erkennen dass alle beim alkohol sollte
man seine grenzen kennen und man sollte
auch bei atv seine grenzen kennen meine
persönliche grenze ist an diesem punkt
jetzt erreicht das gebe ich mir nicht
also sorry wenn ihr das so weiter sehen
wollt dann könnt ihr aber ich bin
einfach ich vorgeschlagen das video und
schreibt einmal in die kommentare was
eure persönliche prognose ist was kommt
als nächstes bei rtl 2 meine frau ist
süchtig nach restmüll oder doch meinen
sohn knabbert gerne alte autoreifen
werden kreativ in den kommentaren das
wollten wir leute ich größere augen
bis zum nächsten mal macht's gut